au départ les prisons ne sait pas ce que
c'est
on pense que les prisons c'est un
endroit ça risque avait dit Giscard
d'Estaing un moment donné il avait dit
les prisons c'est la privation de
liberté rien d'autre mais pas du tout
c'est la privation de liberté et tout
autre
alors on savait que certains hommes
politiques que certains partis
politiques rackettaient les entreprises
mais ce que vous racontez dans votre
livre intitulé il ne me reste que
l'honneur aux éditions privées c'est que
certains hommes politiques ou certains
partis politiques rackettaient
directement les banques tout à fait
quand des hold-ups financés la politique
c'est le sous-titre de votre livre alors
on va voir votre vie on va voir comment
vous êtes arrivés à faire ça et surtout
on va apprendre quelque chose je pense
ce soir je pense alors au départ vous
êtes un petit chef d'entreprise actif et
laborieux vous avez quelques employés
dont vous avez du mal à payer les
salaires et à l'âge de 35 ans vous voyez
s'écrouler 10 ans de travail tout à fait
alors un jour vous convoquez vos
employés pour leur annoncer leur
licenciement mais devant leur révolte et
puis devant le mal que ça vous fait
aussi vous décidez de ne pas aller
jusqu'au bout et vous déchirer leur
lettre de licenciement d'abord il y a
une chose c'est que j'ai une une de mes
assistantes ma secrétaire qui a un petit
bébé qui n'a pas de père qui est un
petit bébé son petit bébé malade et si
elle ne soigne pas son petit bébé c'est
ce qu'elle est en train de me dire il
risque elle risque l'amener à l'hôpital
avec énormément de problèmes et elle me
dit Jean-Claude si tu peux pas me payer
ça va être terrible pour moi il faut
absolument que tu me payes alors ça vous
recevez ça en plein coeur comme un
poignard et c'est difficile de le sentir
après et puis en même temps de là je
vois un homme qui a dans les 55 ans et
cet homme là est en train de me dire
mais enfin tu vas quand même pas
abandonner notre entreprise ça fait des
années moi je suis à l'âge de la
retraite bientôt si jamais tu abandonnes
notre boîte je suis foutu alors il faut
absolument que tu tiennes tu te démerdes
comme tu veux mais il faut que tu
tiennes alors dans la folie dans
l'inconscience j'ai dit je vais tenir
ouais et j'ai tenu alors pour continuer
à faire tourner votre entreprise vous
devez trouver de l'argent et vous
décidez de braquer votre propre banque
et tout faut être fou
mais j'étais fou j'étais fou j'étais
complètement allumé dans ma façon d'être
je voulais toujours essayer de faire le
meilleur et je me suis rendu compte qu'à
un moment donné j'allais au pire alors
comment ça se passe vous avez un
revolver factice un revolver factice
avec ma propre bagnole je suis allé
braquer ma propre banque
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit quand ils vous
ont vu arriver les mecs ils vont gagner
ils ont vu arriver les Pieds Nickelés
mais vous en reconnaît tout de suite
vous étiez pas
il a tourné barjot quoi il a
complètement tourné barjot dans sa vie
le directeur de banque s'est demandé
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce
qu'il y a mais quand vous avez un
revolverfactis vous ne savez pas qu'il
est factice s'il est bien fait vous ne
le savez pas et la personne que vous
braquez en face de vous elle est là la
même peur et la même émotions et le
tremble de la même façon que si vous
aviez un vrai frein mais ces gens-là
vous les côtoyer au moins une fois par
semaine donc d'un seul coup vous allez
vous leur faites peur vous les humilier
vous les voulez vous les braquer et je
leur demande humblement pardon ce soir
devant vous pour leur avoir fait autant
de mal et vous tirez combien de ce
braquage quand vous faites un braquage
vous le faites pas tout seul vous
trouvez toujours deux connards qui
viennent avec vous moi j'ai trouvé deux
connards pour venir avec moi ils sont
venus très facilement ça se rencontrer
facilement on a eu 10 briques
c'est-à-dire que 100000 francs voilà
100000 balles quoi donc et à partir de
ce moment là
une fois que vous avez partagé avec les
deux autres il vous reste quoi de quoi
payer un mois de salaire à vos employés
de quoi payer un mois de salaire à mes
employés voilà et à partir de ce moment
là je me dis ben demain je vais aller
embarquer une autre
parce qu'il faut absolument que je paye
ces trois mois de salaire et vous y
allez pas vous prenez 8 ans et c'est à
dire que il a été très facile de me
prendre puisque j'avais à ce moment là
mon bureau il était au 72 Champs-Élysées
et les flics sont venus ils m'ont
regardé ils m'ont dit c'est toi
Jean-Claude dag j'ai dit oui pourquoi il
me dit ah braqué ta banque je lui dis
oui pourquoi
on va te mettre sur les bracelets
pourquoi et ben il me dit parce que tu
as braqué ta banque aujourd'hui tu es
devenu un criminel ah bon allez un
criminel on me met les bracelets en
prison et je me retrouve en prison et là
je me rends compte au fur et à mesure
des années qui passent la
déshumanisation d'un homme qui est mis
en prison parce qu'au départ les prisons
ne sait pas ce que c'est on pense que
les prisons c'est un endroit vous savez
ce qu'avait dit Giscard d'Estaing un
moment donné il avait dit les prisons
c'est la privation de liberté rien
d'autre mais pas du tout c'est la
privation de liberté et tout autre
Jean-Claude vous raconter la prison et
j'ai appris quelque chose sur la prison
en lisant votre bouquin c'est la
Jeannette je savais pas que ça existait
tu sais ce que c'est une Jeannette alors
une Jeannette c'est un vagin artificiel
que confectionne les prisonniers à
l'aide d'une serviette éponge pliée en
deux enfoncé dans un tube de Benco de
Benco avec une gueule en plastique un
peu crème Nivea voilà et puis vous avez
vous trouver toujours avec de bons
matons vous trouvez toujours des images
porno
des images pornos américaines
du scotch et les carrément au bas d'une
table à la hauteur même de de votre
façon de pratiquer si je puis dire et à
partir de ce moment-là vous vous ça fait
trois ans que vous avez pas une femme
que vous savez pas ce que c'est qu'on
avait pas embrassé qui que ce soit que
bon voilà donc à partir de ce moment là
la folie vous rentre en tête vous voyez
les photos pornographiques qui sont
devant vous et à partir de ce moment-là
vous avez deux façons vous suicidé ou
vous vous suicidez avec la Jeannette et
à partir du moment où vous pénétrez la
jeunesse vous êtes mort
vous êtes sexuellement mort parce que un
jour vous allez sortir de prison un jour
vous allez rencontrer une femme une
belle femme vous allez essayer de
d'avoir avec elle une relation vous
allez essayer de lui plaire et puis ça
va arriver effectivement cette femme là
vous trouvez agréable
gentil sentimental elle va vous amener
chez elle elle va vous amener dans son
lit vous allez avoir effectivement les
premières émotions et au moment où vous
allez vous approchez de cette femme
moment où vous allez pardonnez-moi
pénétrer cette femme la Jeannette vous
arrive en pleine gueule et à partir de
ce moment-là c'est le hurlement total
c'est-à-dire c'est la décomposition
totale et tout le monde se met à hurler
et c'est fini alors vous racontez aussi
le QHS de Tarbes où vous êtes enchaîné
jour et nuit pendant 98 jours et les
matins vous pissent dessus quand vous
arrivez en prison à un moment donné vous
perdez tout sens de la réalité et au fur
et à mesure où les mois passent vous
devenez un légume au bout de trois ans
vous avez deux solutions ou vous devenez
un mec qui va être une balance et qui va
être une ordure qui va autrement dit qui
va cesser d'être un homme ou alors vous
vous dites je vais essayer de me
regarder droit dans la glace et de pas
me cracher dans la gueule je veux me
regarder dans la glace je veux rester un
homme quoi qu'il arrive et
automatiquement le directeur de la
prison qu'est-ce qu'il se dit ça c'est
un caïd si le mec balance pas c'est que
fatalement
j'ai refusé de balancer vous savez que
HS vous savez pourquoi j'ai refusé de
lancer parce que je suis chrétien et que
je crois en Dieu et que pour moi quand
j'ai fait mon séminaire et quand ma mère
qui m'a éduqué me disait quand tu as
quelqu'un de malheureux auprès de toi ne
l'abat pas ne fais pas quelque chose
contre lui au contraire sors-le alors
moi quand je voyais un de mes amis
taulards qui faisait une connerie devant
un maton et quand m'a-t-on me disait
mais toi tu l'as vu ce qu'il faisait bah
je disais non chef moi j'ai pas vu ce
qu'il faisait moi et donc je savais et
non au fur et à mesure les matins se
sont dit ce mec balance pas il a la
carrure ou l'envergure d'un voyou à
partir de ce moment-là les voyous eux se
disent et si c'était vraiment un voyou
ce mec donc il faut récupérer et à
partir du moment où vous récupère vos
rentrez dans le domaine du grand
banditisme alors justement en prison
vous frayez avec le grand banditisme
vous rencontrez un dénommé Rosenthal
vous donnez amis et quand vous sortez de
prison vous découvrez qu'en fait vous
êtes toujours un prisonnier mais
prisonnier de votre statut
d'extola et que la réinsertion est
impossible en fait pour un extrella
travailler c'est un privilège d'une
certaine façon oui c'est impossible pour
la bonne raison c'est que si demain je
trouve un travail par exemple je ne sais
pas dans un de vos studio et que les
flics arrivent pour voir si je travaille
bien si vous êtes content de moi si je
fais bien mon boulot donc
automatiquement les gens vont
collaborateurs ils vont se dire mais
attends
[Musique]
donc là si les flics viennent le voir
c'est un mec qui sort de prison il a
quelque chose à se reprocher et
automatiquement à partir du moment où
les flics ne vous lâchent plus les
directeurs d'entreprise qui au départ
sont d'accord de vos employés mais vous
foutent littéralement à la porte voilà
donc là vous décidez de replonger un
jour vous avez rendez-vous avec une
prostituée rue Godot de Mauroy parce
qu'il faut dire que l'affaire se passe
au début des années 70 à l'époque où la
rue Godot de Mauroy voulait encore dire
quelque chose elle doit vous fournir une
arme et là vous êtes kidnappé par ce
Rosenthal ce grand caïd que vous avez
rencontré à Fresnes et puis que vous
avez revu à Melun il a ce Rosenthal vous
raconte son business alors il vous
explique qu'à l'aide d'une dizaine
d'extollars il braque des banques pour
le compte d'homme politique tout à fait
que c'est très grave ce que vous ce que
vous annoncez là dans ce bouquin c'est à
dire que vous dites aujourd'hui c'est
qu'en fait donc il y a des hommes
politiques
qui ont à leur service des bandits qui
vont braquer des banques pour financer
leurs campagnes électorale très
exactement ça n'engage que vous mais
vous savez que vous dites ça n'engage le
pour moi je l'accepte dans mon livre je
dis également que je n'ai pas peur de
mourir si quelqu'un se voyait rattraper
par mon histoire et qui se disent on ne
sait jamais ce que va raconter ce dagues
jusqu'où il va aller donc on va lui
[ __ ] une balle dans la tête et je veux
que ces gens là sachent que je suis prêt
à mourir pour dire la vérité pas pour
dire un menson mais pour dire la vérité
alors je dis la vérité alors
pardonnez-moi Thierry mais je dis la
vérité et celui qui a écrit la préface
qui est un juge le juge Alpha qui est
Eric halfène dans la préface dit non
seulement que je dis la vérité mais il
dit lui-même que il a connu des
braqueurs de banques lui disant que les
braquages qu'ils avaient fait la moitié
du butin des braquages aller chez les
auteurs
il dit aussi qu'il regrette que vous ne
donniez pas les noms euh des gens pour
qui vous avez fait ça alors
effectivement vous utilisez des des
pseudos mais quand on cherche un peu
c'est pas très compliqué en fait quand
vous êtes recruté par un des caïdes par
des mafieux la première des choses on
vous donne trois règles générales la
première des règles c'est tu ne diras
jamais le nom de la personne pour qui tu
travailles mais aujourd'hui ni demain
sinon tes flingué il y en a qui ont été
ministre oui à droite
oui à gauche oui bien alors le plus fou
de votre bouquin c'est pas tellement ça
c'est que les braquages sont négociés
c'est à dire que quand vous pénétrez
dans une banque avec vos comparts
dans une banque et que vous avez votre
partenaire principal qui dit c'est en
hold-up et que vous voyez les gens qui
lèvent les mains et qu'à un moment donné
vous croisez quelqu'un comme Monsieur
Baffie vous voyez qu'il vous sourit vous
dites merde quand même il me sourit
quand même un petit peu bizarre qui me
sourit alors que j'ai un flingue ou une
mitraillette à la main bon alors déjà
ensuite vos enfants c'est une porte pas
moi mon partenaire en France une porte
là vous voyez quelqu'un qui se lève
doucement c'est le directeur de la
banque ou tout au moins le coût
directeur ou totalement l'intéresse pas
et lui se lève aussi et à ce moment là
il vous fait comme ça
c'est par là
c'est par là vous y allez vous y allez
c'est qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
sang ne coule jamais
le sang ce qu'on appelle des braquages à
l'amiable quoi
je connais complètement négocier avec
certains directeurs ou directeur de
banque ou autre et avec les pouvoirs
mafieux et les pouvoirs politiques alors
les banques sont remboursés
automatiquement par les assurances oui
bien sûr donc il y a pas de souci en
fait il y a pas de souci est-ce que vous
dit dans votre bouquin c'est que les
gens qui ont accepté ça c'est à dire les
banques qui ont accepté ça les patrons
de banque qui ont accepté ça évidemment
été récompensés quand les hommes
politiques en question arrivaient au
pouvoir en fait
je peux pas imaginer que ces directeurs
ou ce directeur de banque soit assez con
pour ne pas demander
quelque chose derrière un petit
avancement
quelque chose qui puisse leur permettre
de pas rester le petit directeur de
banque lambda alors que il serait mieux
qu'il lui rentre dans un parti politique
alors vous dites qu'il y a des équipes
comme ça en fait qui opérait à l'époque
dans toute la France vous n'étiez qu'une
des équipes il y en avait au moins 5 ou
6 en France moi ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il y avait en tous les cas
l'équipe de Mémé Guérini qui était à
Marseille dans tout le monde connaissait
l'équipe de Mémé Guérini avec
bon vous alliez à ce moment là à Lyon
vous aviez Momo le Lyonnais au moins le
Lyonnais il était archi connu au moment
où le Lyonnais
mais aussi il y a des gens comme par
exemple
de ça tout le monde à la Suisse
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on a fait les frères
zen les frères Zemmour il faut quand
même pas oublier que les frères Zemmour
en 1979 ont tous été fusillés les trois
ont été finis à Paris si on a eu le fils
les trois ont été fusillés à Paris et
Édouard qui était à Amérique
à Miami il a été tué la même nuit vous
pensez que c'est à cause de ça
fatalement c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné un homme politique c'est le grand
problème de l'homme politique quand il
est arrivé très haut il se prend pour
Dieu et à partir du moment où il se
prend pour Dieu pas tous fort
heureusement mais certains qu'à partir
de ce moment-là et bien les hommes
politiques tout le monde était d'accord
avec tout le monde pour que ça se passe
très bien tu crois que Besançon
tu leur rapporte le courrier peut-être
les mandats peut-être qu'il garder en
snow a vérifié
vous croyez que le slogan du Crédit
Lyonnais le pouvoir de dire oui ça vient
de là
c'est peut-être une très bonne chose
[Applaudissements]
il ne me reste que le meurge Jean-Claude
dague c'est publié aux éditions privées
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
tu en penses quoi toi
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous a caché la
vérité on nous cache la vérité depuis 30
ou 40 ans tous ceux qui sont au pouvoir
nous cache de la vérité je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui celui qui nous gouverne
nous cache des vérités importantes
Jean-Claude il y a prescription pour la
plupart des délits non pour pouvoir être
devant vous ce soir il fallait qu'il y
ait un minimum de 20 ans et 25 ans pour
certaines choses ça fait 29 ans que ça
s'est passé il y a prescription
aujourd'hui il y a une prescription
en étant correct et honnête mais que si
je l'avais ouverte il y a 10 ans c'est
quoi ce bruit c'est pas grave j'ai pas
peur je suis prêt je suis prêt à mourir
s'il faut mourir pour la vérité pour la
vérité pour la vérité en tout cas ça
fera un beau sujet de film où j'ai eu
peur j'ai reculé
merci Jean-Claude merci de votre
témoignage et bravo pour votre courage
merci beaucoup et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna latitude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu